congratulations on this series I really
love this one it's such an incredible
twisting sort of mystery
um you know when this came your way I
know that Jennifer and Gary were already
cast but were you familiar with the book
like how excited were you to get started
in this one I was I didn't I hadn't read
the book I was so I read the scripts
um and I was very yeah I was very
excited I was very I it was one of those
where I couldn't
I wanted to guess it I wanted to figure
it out I wanted to be clever enough but
I didn't I didn't see what was coming I
was it was really
it was very surprising and it was it was
clearly
incredibly well written
um
both Laura and Josh I didn't know they
were a couple at all I had no idea and I
was like so impressed that they could
could do this together yeah um and uh
that was what I you know I was like this
character is it's so confusing on many
levels it was such a puzzle yeah and I
thought this is interesting I'd like to
to see if I can
Farm away through this and he is such an
interesting character Owen like he's
very layered there's so much more to him
than meets the eye and I'm curious what
do you think the words protect her
reveals about his personality well I
think that that it
what I like about any good writing is
that even when you have massive twists
and surprises it's all grounded in in a
in a in a in a in a truthful character
even a character that lies you know the
character that that makes up crazy
stories if you believe that the core of
them then you can kind of get away with
a lot and I think that's what's done so
well in in in this in this piece because
um
they set up the Love Story between
Hannah and Owen very very well and of
course the love between the father and
daughter yeah um and you really believe
that even when you when you question it
it's been it's been you know the the
seat has been made and and that is is
yeah that's why it that's why it works
and that that's why I think the payoff
at the end is is a real payoff because
it's it's not a it's not a there's a
logic underneath yeah emotional logic
that's uh
yeah very well made yeah and I know that
Hannah made some very tough choices in
this series um but Owen made even more
difficult choices and I noticed that
you've played a lot of characters even
like sir Jamie from Game of Thrones like
they these are characters who are rooted
in like the need to protect their family
and so what has been the biggest draw to
a character like that for you and what
have you learned about yourself playing
this kind of role I don't know what if
I've learned what I've learned
um
you know about myself I think that I
need to I've never had therapy maybe I
should go and have some therapy so I can
I can answer these questions better but
I think that what what I I what I can
my way into this character was exactly
that that I can relate to relate to that
at the end of the day love is is kind of
the most important thing we have the
most important force in our lives like
the the relationships we we we
uh we find ourselves in the the whether
it's family of of close friends those
are the most important things those are
the ones you you're willing to go
go far for uh of course here it's a it's
a drama it's a very he's had to make
some very extreme choices in his life
but they're also they all came out of uh
of uh you know um
a good heart if you will yeah no a very
good heart I mean to have this type of
father who still wants to protect his
family it just it means a lot and I I
was wondering how you created that sort
of relationship with Jennifer and angary
because you know you guys have such
great chemistry together on screen even
in those little tiny moments we get to
see these flashbacks and how did you
build that to you know create such a
convincing sort of you know dynamic that
you guys are a real unit well it was
yeah first of all those two ladies are
just
wonderful people to be around and then
they have a you know very they're very
sharp they're very a lot of fun and they
also happen to be on top of that
brilliant actress so you you have you
kind of I just had to react to what they
were doing and and you know
follow their lead
um
so so yeah that was really it
it's a very in the funny thing is it's a
very it's obviously a very dark story in
many ways because it's it's it's it you
know it's it's horrible what happens
yeah you know it's it's kind of this
nightmarish
situation that that that
the good thing was we had a lot of fun
on set
um which made it it was it was real Joy
yeah it really looked like you guys were
just like an actual little family unit
of three people and it was so sweet to
see
um you know knowing that the author
Laura Dave helped developed this for TV
with hello sunshine and we have seen
shows that have worked outside Source
materials I'm wondering if we ever did
get a season two without spoiling
anything where would you ideally like to
see this show go if you know what we
with what we saw in the ending the only
thing I learned from reading this when I
read the first I was I I I wouldn't know
I'm I know I would be surprised I would
love to find out but I I have you know
we'll see what happens I I don't know if
they have any plans for future Seasons
but but uh in a future well if I had to
choose I would love to be uh that it
would be a present that no one would be
a present-day character throughout
because it's been so much I mean it's
been so much fun to play this this
puzzle of of memories if you will
um but you know I know that that Laura
had you know when she was writing a book
she had uh you know 100 pages on on what
happens
what Owen was doing and why he was doing
this but but uh obviously this the way
it's done now works just perfectly
because it's it's about it's a mystery
but it's really about a love service
reading a mother and a daughter yeah it
really is and um my last question for
you is you know there are a lot of
scenes with Owen that I thought were so
interesting they opened up so many
layered doors to him like understanding
who this person is and you know I'm
wondering without spoiling it of course
what scene do you think was the most
quintessential scene for knowing who
this person is oh I think that I think
it's a very it's a scene
um
when she
when she when Hannah asked so and
um what defines him and he says I'll do
anything for my daughter and I think
that that is really the key yeah
um because because that is what's what
what you find out later said everything
in motion
um and and led to that moment and then
of course going forward I would say oh
and if he has to learn anything I guess
if you ask me what have I learned yeah
if I write notes
I can they should be longer than three
letters yeah all three words you know
you can do more I mean you can write a
little more you really can
yeah it was a little in theory to have
that much for the love of his life and
he couldn't share any more with her and
then his daughter gets a little bit more
but I'm not gonna complain it's an
amazing series it is so great Nikolai
thank you so much for your time today
I'm really excited for everyone to see
it and uh congrats again I I'm a huge
fan of yours uh my dad's a huge fan and
he was very very excited that I was
talking to you so um say hi to your dad
I will I'm on the David I'm the favorite
favorite daughter today I guess but um
thank you so much I really appreciate it